Hidalgo n'allez pas mettre des grands
géants pour voir les matchs
quelle hypocrisie mais sans déconner
mais quelle hypocrisie elle va pas
mettre des crochets pour voir les matchs
mais qui elle va pénaliser les Français
les gens qui ont envie de voir les
matchs elle va pénaliser
les couilles excusez-moi ils auraient
empêché ils auraient dit bon c'est pas
la Coupe du monde mais c'est pas la
peine de se réveiller là ça fait des
années qu'on sait qu'elle va se passer
maintenant qui se réveille et tous les
maires du Louvre pas me décrochant mais
c'est mon passe sanctionner les les gars
qui organisé la Coupe du Monde
ah ouais [ __ ] tu as vu on peut mettre
des grands géants et je vais défoncer
tout le monde en tout cas
plus jamais au Parc des Princes
exactement on sera plus jaloux
les entreprises du CAC 40 le Qatar il a
implanté partout à Paris bien sûr sur
les Champs-Élysées moi la personne qui
s'occupe des interdits du Qatar en
France il m'avait emmené sur les
Champs-Élysées